coucher avec un mec carrément con mais
très très beau fait ou à faire
ça
alors Lisa vous êtes
vous êtes redevenu brune
oui je n'ai jamais été blondes
dans le miroir
je me disais c'est pas moi c'est qui ça
non c'était pas votre couleur blonde
vous êtes mieux comme ça quand même
vraiment comme ça on vous reconnaît moi
je me souviens de vous vous souvenez
quand vous venez au Palace dans lunettes
noires pour Nuit Blanche vous aviez un
petit accroche-cœur comme ça sur le
front à l'époque de
ça ça fait longtemps
vous revenez avec un nouvel album ça
s'appelle The Moment et pourquoi avoir
attendu trois ans
j'attends toujours et tout le monde
repart à chaque fois d'un come-back de
licence ville donc je fais des combats
depuis 16 ans chaque fois que je fais un
album
je crois que
je préfère ne mettre sur le marché
canalbum dont je suis vraiment fière
tous les trois ans plutôt que de lancer
un album médiocre tous les ans je crois
que je ne serai pas encore là si j'avais
fait ça très bien alors vous avez
travaillé avec le fameux Trévor orne
quel producteur de statue de Frankie
Goes tollywood de style et l'album tout
nouvel album est vachement bien le
premier single s'appelle traite moi
comme une femme twitt me like a wow
parce que ça veut dire que vous n'aimez
pas les hommes vulnérables
pour moi c'est l'histoire d'une femme
mûre qui dit ne me traitait plus comme
si j'avais 22 ou 23 ans les règles du
jour ont changé
pour me sortir je n'aime pas envie
d'aller au McDonald's et qu'ensuite tu
vas voir tes amis et du football des
règles ont changé alors dans le clip
vous êtes dans les bras d'une femme
habillée en homme à un moment est-ce que
vous avez déjà essayé en vrai
non non on va voir où vous en êtes en
tant que femme on va faire une interview
fait ou à faire
[Musique]
alors puisque vous voulez quand vous
traite comme une femme on va voir donc
où vous en êtes est-ce que vous avez une
meilleure copine à qui vous raconter vos
histoires tous les soirs au téléphone
j'ai une meilleure copine à qui je dis
presque tout au téléphone tenir un
journal intime fait ou à faire
je tiens un journal tombé amoureuse d'un
gros connard fait ou à faire
toute femme l'a fait un jour dans sa vie
faire une soirée pyjama avec des copines
fait ou à faire
c'est
tricher en mettant du coton dans son
soutien-gorge fait ou à faire
bien sûr
coucher avec un inconnu dans les
toilettes d'une boîte de nuit fait ou à
faire attends homme ou femme les
toilettes
devant une penderie pleine fait ou à
faire
tous les jours avoir un accident en
conduisant la voiture de votre copain
fait ou à faire
j'ai fait ça aussi
[Musique]
avec une femme mais jamais de relation
sexuelle avec une femme non se faire
tromper par son mec fait ou à faire
voilà
coucher avec un mec carrément con mais
très très beau fait ou à faire
sortir avec un homme marié fait ou à
faire
non jamais fait la chirurgie esthétique
fait ou à faire
non
mais peut-être
dans 10 ans j'y penserai posé nu dans un
magazine fait ou à faire
non mais je me suis montré dans des
clips vidéos
donc je n'ai jamais été photographié nu
mais on m'a filmé nu sortir sans
sous-vêtement parce que c'est agréable
fait ou à faire
pour faire du shopping fait ou à faire
remettre la bretelle de son
soutien-gorge mine de rien mais parce
que ça excite les mecs fait ou à faire
j'ai jamais su que ça rendait les hommes
fous
je le fais tout le temps
dis à son meilleur ami qu'on veut pas
gâcher une telle amitié en couchant
ensemble fait ou à faire
je l'ai dit et on a quand même couché
ensemble on est toujours ensemble
une aventure avec un français pendant
une émission de télévision fait ou à
faire
avoir plusieurs orgasmes à la suite fait
ou à faire
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu